want to be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life
and learn what billionaires think about
bitcoin and
other cryptocurrencies enjoy
okay let's kick it off with what does
bill gates think he's not
bullish on it tesla could potentially
make more money
from its bitcoin investment this year
than
profits from electric cars in all of
2020.
what's your take on that what what's
your bitcoin take and
and the fact that the price can just go
up or down based on a simple tweet from
him
well look elon has tons of money and
he's
very sophisticated so you know i'm i
don't worry
that uh you know his bitcoin will sort
of randomly go up or down i do think
people get
bought into these manias who may not
have as much money to spare so i'm
not uh bullish on
bitcoin and you know my general thought
would be
uh that you know if you have less money
than elon you should probably
uh watch out why aren't you bullish on
bitcoin
it's it's look there are things we
invest in in society that produce
output uh bitcoin happens to use a lot
of energy
uh it happens to promote and not
anonymous transactions they're not
reversible transactions
our the gates foundation does a lot in
terms of digital currency
uh but those are things where you can
see
who's making the transaction uh so
digital money is a good thing
uh uh and you know there's a different
approach that's
local currency and attributed and you
know deals with all the money laundering
and terrorism type regulations
and yet gives you the very com the
convenience and the low cost of
transaction
uh and so you know our foundation is
very proud that in the pandemic a lot of
the countries we funded to do this were
able to get money out
to their citizens very very efficiently
so
that's something that it's not got the
visibility of bitcoin
but the move towards digital money uh
that we're very engaged in
is a super positive thing uh that
eventually will get to
even the poorest countries what does
elon musk think
it's a replacement for cash i'm neither
hero they're on bitcoin
yeah um
yeah what did you think when you read
like satoshi's white paper for the first
time we're like oh it's pretty
interesting
that was pretty clever it's
it's just like the things yeah
this always gets like the crypt of
people angry but um
i think uh there are
there are transactions that are um
not within the balance of the law and
those and there are obviously many laws
in different countries
and normally cash is used for these
transactions
um but but cat but in order for
illegal transactions to occur those
the cash must also be used for legal
transactions you need
an illegal to legal bridge
um that's where crypto comes in
so it's like kind of the dark net stuff
it can't be entirely
dog because otherwise how do you buy
normal stuff
and cash these days is used just much
rarer
it's hard it's like increasingly
difficult to use cash some places you
can't use cash at all
yeah true so there's a forcing function
for
transactions that are
illegal quasi-legal and in some cases
legal but they've got to have some it's
got to be
both legal and illegal it doesn't count
otherwise otherwise you simply
it can't just be transactions within an
illegal economy because how do you buy
like you know food in a house or
something you know
you must have illegal to illegal bridge
um so
where i see crypto as effectively as a
replacement for
cash but not
as a replacement for as a primary uh
not as i do not see crypto being the
primary database
so now this is something i've taken
being like
i'm being judgmental about crypto and
it's actually i think there's a lot of
things that are legal that shouldn't be
illegal
um um but you know
so it's not as though
i think that sometimes governments just
have too many laws about the
mission that they should actually have
so many things that are illegal
didn't you say like on mars there would
be less laws hopefully
yeah also if you want to have more
self-confidence and self-belief i've
created
a special free program called 254
because the sign says that it takes up
to 254 days of consecutive action to
build a habit
so what i'm gonna do is send you an
unlisted video to your email
every day for 254 days for free
to help your confidence and self-belief
shift forward
the link to join is in the description
below i've always been passionate
some people thought you know it's more
ocd than anything else
starting companies like staring into
your bus and eating glass
what does chamath palahapatia think buy
and hold i've always maintained and i
would just tell you today as well
that this is an instrument that you use
as a hedge i don't think this is
something that you trade
and the more that people obsess and
focus in my opinion at least
on what the price action is the more
that it will confound you the more it
will frustrate you the more that it will
look
correlated to other assets but the
reality is it's fundamentally not
because it is underpinned
by a set of beliefs that are completely
orthogonal
to the orthodoxy that runs the world
today and it is completely the inverse
of how
the financial infrastructure of the
world operates so from my perspective i
still think
that what i talked about sort of eight
or nine years ago still holds which is
as a one percent hedge
in in our portfolio i think of this as
the insurance policy i use to sleep
soundly at night
just in case the central banks and the
governments of the world
step on a land mine that will perform
and so between now and then i just think
the more people obsess about price
action and the more
that they want it to behave like a stock
or a bond the more frustrated they're
going to get they're going to find ways
of connecting dots that don't exist
it's just not what it is the last few
million coins of bitcoin are obviously
going to cost
more energy than the first you know 18
million but in the grand scheme of
things again
this is something that you know in
bitcoin parlance people say huddle
you buy it you hold it you put it away
and honestly i think you hope that you
never need it
because the amount of actual chaos that
will
drive bitcoin appreciation is not
something we actually really want to see
now that being said if it does happen i
think it will create
an enormous power redistribution and it
will push power
it'll push financial accessibility to
the edges
to billions and billions of people and
in that i think there's some
something to be really proud and excited
about what does mark cuban think
that it's a speculation crypto how much
of your dodea have tied up in
cryptocurrencies
so you think it's [ __ ] um i don't
know that it's [ __ ]
but you have to ask how to value it
and people value it in different ways
particularly blockchain
i mean particularly bitcoin so with
bitcoin some people value it as a store
of value
yeah which makes it like baseball cards
art um gold and they have value
they have value because people see value
in it not because they have insurance so
you say they have no intrinsic value
what is the intrinsic value of gold then
i mean minimal intrinsic value for
manufacturing
and jewelry but not enough to justify
the the price of gold that's typical
that it typically trades at
the the delta between the intrinsic
value
the manufacturing slash jewelry and what
it's being sold for what's um
being valued at on markets is what they
call store of value
because people want to invest in it
because they think
if certain circumstances occur that it
looks like a pandemic
whatever it may be yeah that people
other
other there will be potential buyers at
that value
so they see it as storing value and they
do it in gold sounds like you prefer to
own
gold to store value than crypto i prefer
neither right now
okay because i've never been a gold fan
because the like i said the delta
between intrinsic
and trading value is what people
invest and see in it um but
it's no different than tulips it's no
different than baseball cards
it's no different than a lot of
different things because it's only worth
what you think someone else will pay for
you're basically saying it's a
speculation yeah of course okay let's
talk about blockchain to me that is
actually a non-proprietary
utility right why would that in any way
be a storage of value blockchain anybody
blockchain
effectively is software okay so it's a
distributed database that's managed
independently and that inherently
that inherent combination makes it a
utility makes it
software effectively that has value in
utility so when somebody's running
around trying to raise a blockchain
fund that's just a software for hire
fund
in some respects you know but there's a
specific
um you there are there are very unique
use cases for blockchain
so for instance um when when people say
there's no value at
no no intrinsic value to crypto
there they don't really look at the
value of blockchain now when you take
blockchains from different types of
cryptocurrency bitcoin versus ethereum
versus
others there's there's significant
differences
but blockchain blockchain in general
does have
at least a basic intrinsic value not as
high as what the cryptos
trade for but there is basic intrinsic
value i'll give you an example
if for instance there was a blockchain
driven
um general ledger system that had
auditing capabilities
yeah so for instance for a big company
you wanted to have a truly independent
auditor
that would so you would set up a general
ledger system
using blockchains with where an external
third party would be able to look at
different segments
of the general ledger there wouldn't
just be one auditor you could have
made the process more efficient so it
has value there but it makes it not just
more efficient but it makes it
truly independent but there's no no
equity that i can buy in blocks well but
let me finish
imagine if this was a system used for
enron yeah
so that instead of having arthur
anderson doing
their auditing and their accounting and
we know what happened from there
the auditors and the accountants were
there were three different auditors and
accountants
that just using blockchain were able to
look at a specific segment of their
general ledger
and a sick so they would have caught the
fraud earlier they would have caught the
fraud because you couldn't you couldn't
um you couldn't fake out all three of
them so it has utility there i get yeah
and what does ray dalio think you have
to stay informed
because its volatility is so great it's
not an effective storehold of wealth
so it is a speculative vehicle now
highly speculative vehicle
based on blockchain which is a very
impressive technology
so very similar right now i would say to
uh what the internet was let's say in
2000 okay so what the internet was a
fabulous force
blockchain is a fabulous force um and
there will be cryptocurrencies
they will be produced by central banks
by the way as well as they'll be
produced by
you know this marketplace and the
blockchain i'm sold on
has a great concept but whether um
you're going to have which
cryptocurrency is going to be effective
and
and what that'll look like is a whole
different question um
like bitcoin could be blackberry in
other words you can have ethereum come
along
and replace that and that'll all change
and so
um and it is going through this
speculative bubble now
a lot of the particular people are in it
for
a particular you know are they
knowledgeable do we know intrinsic value
that is there that frame of reference or
are you buying it to resell it quickly
and so on those create elements of
bubbles so very interesting
very significant potential with the
blockchain
underneath it potentially valuable what
i would hope
is that it could be very effective as a
medium of exchange
wow that would be a great thing if they
made that very effective quickly so
you're using it
and that you can create enough stability
in that price
so that the uncertainty of the price
movement
doesn't stand as an impediment to its
usage as a currency or it's a
storehold of wealth now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you just get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
got to take action but
when you get motivated and then you
create a specific plan of action for
when and how you're gonna do it your
number jumps from 35
to 91 percent chance of following
through and when you commit to somebody
else
like posting down here in the comments
below that number jumps to 95
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down the comments below so you
can follow through and i can celebrate
you today you're going to learn
something that you guys should
understand
it's called crypto everybody who made
money started early in
crypto i mean they you know went up and
down went from a dollar to 5 million
dollars to
10 cents to 300 million dollars and down
again
and you know the mount cox went bankrupt
which everybody loved all the old guys
loved that one
but in the meantime crypto or
specifically bitcoin is hanging on
and so i made a lot of my money
investing in silver in 1964
and it was back then it was really worth
10 cents
today it's worth three dollars but
anyway that's that's the name of the
game
get a little bit early then i bought my
first gold coin in 1972
in hong kong because it was illegal for
americans to own gold
so the key to success is being early
getting on the train and the reason i
say the idiots out there are still
saving dollars you got to be kidding me
you know about trump not paying taxes
you got to be kidding me on that one
but anyway you better open your mind up
that's what i'm saying so i'm an old guy
i have gold silver and bitcoin and i
love crypto
i don't have any i have a little bit but
the reason i like crypto
is for one reason it's outside
the system it doesn't depend on the fed
the federal reserve bank or the treasury
or wall street now you like wall street
you believe in investing for the long
term in the stock market for your
retirement
i'll take laps around the rollers
repeats tonight you're screwed
i mean you really are screwed up if you
think you're going to retire on that
if you want to know how bitcoin works
and whether you should invest or not
check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe
and i'll see you there if you're a true
adventurer and you really want to throw
the hail mary
you might take 10 and put it in bitcoin
or ethereum
but if you do that you've got to pretend
you've already lost your money